Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Thomas Homer Dixon, who's the executive
director of the Cascade Institute at Royal
Roads University in British Columbia, Canada.
His new book is Commanding Hope The Power We
Have to Renew a World in Peril. Some of you may
may recognize his name because he was also the
author of an article we spoke about in January
called The American Polity is cracked and Might
Collapse. Canada must prepare. It's really great
to have you on today. I appreciate your time.
Speaker 2: Delighted to be with you, David.
Speaker 1: So your article was essentially written
as a cautionary message to Canada about, you know,
us, the traditionally democratic neighbor to
the South, and the possibility that by 2030 the
U.S. could become to use your term a right wing
dictatorship. Can can we start by talking about
that? That's only eight years, relatively short
amount of time. What would be the path for the
U.S. to become that over the next eight years?
Speaker 5: In the article, I postulate that Donald
Trump is reelected in 2024. And that is really
the critical stage in the process that could
see that evolution of American democracy
into an authoritarian regime of some kind
and people have been beating around in the
in the bushes about this using various terms
autocracy, authoritarian regime. But I just
say, look, if we're going to have one person
putting himself above the rule of law in the
United States, then then that is a dictatorship
and we should just call it a dictatorship. So a
critical stage would be Donald Trump's reelection.
I don't know whether he would actually consolidate
the a right wing dictatorship in the United
States. It might take a period of time. It might
be one of his successors. But I think he would put
democracy in the United States in extreme
jeopardy. I don't think there's any doubt
about that. He would return to office with
the goals of vindication and vengeance,
really, and he would be unleashed, given that
it would probably be his last term in office.
And I think that. Creates enormous concern around
the world, not just within the United States,
yes. So this was a warning to Canadian citizens
to start preparing for this possibility.
Speaker 1: The word dictatorship can
mean in practice many different things,
and sometimes there is associations with
police states. You know, just willy nilly
imprisonment of media or political dissidents.
People, as you know, we sometimes say jokingly,
although it's not a joke, accidentally stabbing
themselves 10 times when they happen to,
you know, this type of thing. Which of these
characteristics do you think would be plausible
in such an American circumstance?
Speaker 5: It's a very good question,
I lay out a number of pathways in the article. The
most benign I would be, I would say, is something
resembling and this wouldn't really qualify as a
dictatorship, of course, with something resembling
Viktor Orban's illiberal democracy in Hungary.
Yes. But I think we could go all the way through
to something closer to what we see in Russia right
now with under Vladimir Putin, that seems extreme
and seems implausible. I think for many people,
especially on the liberal end of the spectrum,
but some of the rhetoric that you're hearing
now on the right against media, for instance,
lock them up, shoot them even from people
who are increasingly accepted as part of the
mainstream discourse in the United States.
It's rhetoric that you would expect from
of people who want to impose that kind of
brutality within the American polity. So one
of the points I make within the article is that
a critical development here is the propagation
of what scholars call a hard line security
doctrine in the United States. And it's been
associated with some of the most brutal regimes
that a transition from democracy. And I use the
example of Weimar Germany in the 1920s and 30s
that a transition from democracy to a dictatorship
and a critical element of that process has been
the propagation of hard line security doctrine,
which suggests for people who adhere to
it, that there are individuals within the
society and groups within the society embedded
across the society, within civilian sectors of
the society that are enemies of the state, who
are and enemies of the nation more generally,
and who have to be identified and ostracized
or even eliminated. And that kind of rhetoric
is now becoming much more common on the right
in the United States. And that's a precursor of
of not just not just a soft, authoritarian
regime, but it's the kind of thing you would
see as a precursor for a much more brutal regime
Speaker 1: in the in the aftermath of the 2020
election, which Donald Trump, who lost claimed
that he won. We were, I mean, whether we were
surprised, this is a question. But many of us
were certainly distraught that more than half
of the Republican Party believed it. They they
at least said that they believed that Joe Biden
did not really win that election. Can you talk
a little bit about in this potential dictatorial
slide? How important does it matter whether
a significant portion of the population buys
the lies of the would be dictator?
Speaker 5: Oh, it matters enormously.
It's the one of the critical elements here that
is poison. And again, it's quite similar to
that that false falsehood. The Big Lie is quite
similar to the falsehood that the Nazis used
to to reinforce their own legitimacy. The stab
in the back that the idea gained. Listen to the
sort of the rhetoric of the hard line security
doctrine, the idea that there was a group in this
particular, principally Jews within within Germany
who had conspired against Germany during the
Second World, during the First World War, at the
end of the First World War and had stabbed Germany
in the back and a defeated Germany from within.
And and so the lie that's being propagated now,
the falsehood that the election was stolen from
Donald Trump and and widely believed and accepted
by supposedly somewhere around 70 percent of
Republicans now. Yeah. So what are we looking at?
30 percent of the American electorate, 25 to
30 percent of the American electorate. It you,
you. You can seize power within a
society with a mobilized and coordinated
fraction of the society that large 20 to 30
percent, absolutely 100 percent. If everybody
else is squabbling and disorganized and not
realizing what the nature of the danger is
and not reinforcing the the the institutions of
democracy. It it certainly large enough to impose
a an institutional transition on the society away
from democracy. So yes, that that that falsehood
and the fact that it's widely believed and a
substantial proportion of of Republicans also
believe that violence is justified in returning
Trump to the presidency or would be justified is,
as I say, within the article, it's poisoned within
the body politic of the United States, and it's
coursing through the entire body politic now.
Speaker 1: You mentioned World War Two
and pre-World War Two era Germany. There's been,
I mean, for decades at this point, you hear
some on the American Right and maybe elsewhere say
if the Jews had had guns, the Holocaust wouldn't
have happened. Historians have looked. At this,
it's been widely debunked and explained away. I
am curious about what you imagine. I mean, gun
culture in the United States is very different
than that in Canada. And I'm curious what you
imagine the potential role of civilian own
guns to be in an authoritarian takeover of the
U.S. And this is with the specific reality that
it's definitely more of the folks who believe
the big lie that would be likely to have
the guns. And this is why among many of my
liberal friends, many, many are now saying
I'm not a big gun person, but I don't want them to
be the only ones with the guns. Give us a sense,
whether you know you have some thoughts as to
the role of civilian owned guns in such a world.
Speaker 5: Mm-Hmm. You know,
it's enormously important.
So in a sense, and you're being very gentle on
your description of the situation, by the way,
in a sense, what we have is is the development of
an arms race and a weapons race between different
ideological camps in this highly polarized society
and a disintegration of what social scientists
call social capital, which is the trust, the bonds
of trust and reciprocity that help bind societies
together. Societies with high social capital tend
to prosper, solve their problems effectively and
those without doubt. And we're seeing that it's
a terrible degenerative process. And I think guns
are a really important element of that because
they induce a lot of fear. And it's just as you
were describing in the fear causes the retreat
to what what political scientists call a kind
of self-help situation where you feel you have to
take care of yourself. I mean, we all feel that.
And now the irony is that the Second Amendment
and the gun culture in the United States
is ideologically justified on the right by the
fear of a tyrant. Right? That that we need to
we need to maintain our capacity to rebel against
an authoritarian state because that's part of the
it's almost the civic religion of the United
States going back to the revolution and
justifiably and in a lot of ways, of
course, the Second Amendment is completely,
wildly misinterpreted from its original intent.
But yes, I would say that the folks who tend
to support an authoritarian shift or would
support an authoritarian shift in the United
States who are not supportive of democracy
as it currently exists in the United States,
will tend to have a disproportionate number of
these weapons 400 million currently, I think,
in the civilian population in the United States.
So it's just breathtaking. Now what would happen
at you have all these heavily armed people
around and you have a the implementation of an
authoritarian regime which would have elements
of a plutocracy, probably because it would be
supported by wealthy certain elements,
wealthy elites in the United States.
What's going to happen to all these folks
who are heavily armed who suddenly find
that they actually really are living within a
dictatorship? And that's an interesting question.
You might actually find that there's a great
deal of opposition from folks who might have
otherwise supported or originally supported
the shift in the institutions. At this point,
where it's complete speculation, we have really no
idea where things could go. But it's again, what I
was doing in my article was just opening up these
questions because in Canada, we need police need
to start considering them and talking about them.
Speaker 1: What do you think the role has been
from seeing what's happening in Russia, for
example, or in other countries around the world
where I mean, really, it's it's these sort of
authoritarians that Donald Trump sometimes played
coy with and sometimes even expressed admiration
for? What sort of effect do you think that has
had on the population in the United States?
Speaker 5: So this is a really interesting
question and development and
somewhat unexpected. I mean,
I've been watching Putin this buildup of arms
since since last year, and I actually felt
that it was quite likely he was going to attack
Ukraine. But I hadn't expected, first of all,
what we've seen as a democratic rallying around
the world, the rallying of democratic countries
to come together in the defense of Ukraine and all
of the folks like Viktor Orban and Jared Bolsonaro
and Marine Le Pen in France. All of the folks
who had cozied up to Putin in various ways
heading for the exits because all of a sudden
they've been substantially delegitimized. I mean,
this is a real world lesson in what happens
when you get a dictatorship. Dictatorships tend
to go to war. Democracies don't go to war with
each other. It's one of the strongest empirical
laws or generalizations in the social sciences
that's called the democratic peace hypothesis.
If you end up with something like Putin or an
authoritarian regime, you're much more likely
to go to war because what happens with these
folks and. This is part of what's happening
in Russia is as their legitimacy declines
internally because authoritarian regimes tend
not to solve their problems very well, they have
economic crises and things as their legitimacy
and popularity declines internally. They pick
fights with their enemies or with external enemies
and try to build up the leaders, try to
build up their authority and popularity
internally by picking fights externally. So, so
we're getting a very vivid lesson in the kind
of world we will be creating if we give up on
democracy. And I think in an extraordinary way,
this is a silver lining from this this war.
I mean, it's a terrible, terrible situation,
but it sort of reminded everyone in the world
what's at stake. And I think I think it actually
puts Donald Trump in an interesting way and
something of a vulnerable position in the
United States as we come into, for instance, the
midterms and the presidential election campaign.
Speaker 1: That'll be very interesting to
see in terms of what, what impact it has,
for sure. We're going to link to Thomas Homer
Dickson's article that's been the jumping,
jumping off point for our conversation today.
The new book is Commanding Hope The Power We
Have to Renew a World in peril. I so appreciate
your time today. Thank you so much. Thank you.